JESSE WATTERS, DANA PERINO IS
BACK, AND A DAGEN McDOWELL.
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
THERE IS ONLY ONE THING NANCY
LOVES MORE THAN GELATO, LAWYERS.
IN A YEAR WHERE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS SHOULD UNITE AND SPIKE
A GLOBAL VIRUS, HER INSTINCT IS
TO PROTECT THE LAWYERS BY VOWING
TO BLOCK LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
FOR EMPLOYERS IN THE NEXT RELIEF
PACKAGE.
HERE IT IS.
>> WHAT WE WILL NOT SUPPORT US
THE FOLLOWING.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING TO
ESSENTIAL WORKERS, YOU HAVE TO
GO TO WORK BECAUSE YOU ARE
ESSENTIAL, WE PLACE NO
RESPONSIBILITY ON YOUR EMPLOYER
TO MAKE THAT WORKPLACE SAFE, AND
IF YOU GET SICK, YOU HAVE NO
RECOURSE, BECAUSE WE HAVE GIVEN
YOUR EMPLOYER PROTECTION.
AND IF YOU DON’T GO TO WORK
BECAUSE YOU ARE AFRAID OF BEING
SICK AND YOU HAVE THAT JOB
OPPORTUNITY, YOU DON’T GET
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
THIS IS SO UNFAIR.
>> Greg: SO WAIT, WE PLACE NO
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE EMPLOYERS
TO MAKE THE WORKPLACE SAFE?
WHERE THE HILL HAS SHE BEEN?
HIDING UNDERGROUND WITH JOE?
THE GUY WHO READ RIP VAN WINKLE
AND MADE IT HIS POLITICAL
PLAYBOOK.
UNLESS YOU HAVE BEEN
REFRIGERATED LIKE DELICIOUS MINT
CHOCOLATE CHIP FOR SEVEN MONTHS,
YOU HAVE SEEN AN AMAZING
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE SAFETY.
LET’S NOT ASSUME PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO GET BACK TO WORK ARE BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE, THEY ARE MAKING
ADULT DECISIONS STRUGGLING TO
SAVE THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
LIVELIHOOD PROTECTION INSISTS TO
ALLOW CIVILIZATION AND ENOUGH
TIME TO RESTART BEFORE THE
LAWYERS CARVE UP THE CARCASS.
AND WE.
IF A BUSINESS DOES NOT MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS SAFE FOR EMPLOYEES,
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE SAFER
CUSTOMERS.
ANY IDIOT CAN FIGURE THAT OUT.
BUT NANCY IS NOT JUST ANY IDIOT,
SHE IS A LEFT-WING DEMOCRAT,
HOLDING LEFT-WING LAW FORMS
SHOVING 80% OF THEIR DONATIONS
INTO HER PARTY’S POCKET.
AND BECAUSE LAWYERS KNOW THAT
THEY CAN MAKE BILLIONS ON COVID
LITIGATION, WHO CARES IF IT CAN
KEEP SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
RETURNING TO WORK EVER.
WHICH IS WHY SHE PIVOTS TO A HOT
SHOT.
>> LET’S JUST GET TO THE HEART
OF IT.
THE POINT OF ALL OF THIS IS THIS
PRESIDENT, I HAVE A NEW NAME FOR
HIM, MR. MAKE MATTERS WORSE.
HE HAS MADE MATTERS WORSE FROM
THE START, DELAY, DENIAL, THE
HOAX, THE MIRACLE, AND ALL THE
REST.
AND WE ARE IN THE SITUATION
WHERE YOU SAW SOME OF THE
NUMBERS VERY CLEARLY EARLY.
>> Greg: THAT WAS PAINFUL,
LET’S POINT OUT, NANCY GAVE NO
PRACTICAL ADVICE ON DEALING WITH
THE PANDEMIC.
SHE CURRENTLY LAID LOW AND THEN
WAITED TO ARMCHAIR QUARTERBACK
MUCH LATER.
IF SHE HAD ALL THE ANSWERS TO
THE VIRUS, SHE MUST HAVE KEPT
THEM TO HERSELF.
THAT MAKES HER THE REAL VILLAIN
HERE, AND SOMEONE WHO MIGHT HAVE
MORE THAN JUST RUM RAISIN ON HER
HANDS.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, WELCOME BACK TO
THE SHOW.
YOU WERE MISSED.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I DON’T LIKE RUM RAISIN, I THINK
THAT IS THE WORST ICE CREAM OF
ALL ICE CREAMS.
>> Greg: IT IS.
THAT’S WHY ASSUME THAT
NANCY PELOSI WOULD BE EATING IT,
BECAUSE SHE SEEMS LIKE A RUM
RAISIN TYPE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HER DISK
CONDITION, SHE ROADBLOCKS THESE
PACKAGES.
AND OUR OBVIOUS REPLY WOULD BE,
OF COURSE SAFETY IS OUR CONCERN.
WE ARE NOT IDIOTS!
>> Dana: IT’S ALSO NOT TRUE.
SO THERE IS THAT, WAS IT ABOUT
EIGHT WEEKS AGO, MAYBE EVEN MORE
THAT YOU DID A MONOLOGUE BASED
ON A "WASHINGTON POST" ARTICLE
THAT BASICALLY LISTED ALL OF THE
LAWSUITS THAT HAVE BEEN UP UNTIL
THEN AND IT HAD ONLY BEEN ABOUT
SIX WEEKS AND WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH THE PANDEMIC.
SO IMAGINE BETWEEN THEN AND NOW
HOW MANY WE HAVE AND YOU ARE
ABOUT TO SEE A LOT MORE, TALK
ABOUT, I THINK ABOUT ADDICTIONS
AND COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE, NOT
TO MENTION REALTORS.
YOU HAVE SO MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE HAIR SALONS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY HAVE HAD TO BUY
AND INVEST, PUT MONEY INTO
GETTING THE PLEXIGLASS ORGANIZED
SO THAT THEY CAN REOPEN, MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR EMPLOYEES HAVE
ENOUGH MASKS, AND THEY HAVE HAD
TO LIMIT THEIR HOURS FOR CERTAIN
EMPLOYEES.
THEY DON’T WANT TO BE SUED.
THEY DON’T WANT AS YOU SAID,
THEY DON’T WANT THE LIABILITY OF
SOMETHING TO GO WRONG, BECAUSE
THEIR ENTIRE LIVELIHOOD IS
WRAPPED UP IN THEIR BUSINESS.
AND SO, THIS BILL THAT
McCONNELL IS PUTTING FORWARD
DOES NOT SAY THAT A BUSINESS
DOES NOT HAVE TO DO ANYTHING TO
ENSURE SAFETY, IT SAYS THAT IT
DOES.
IT IS SPECIFICALLY IT ABOUT
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS, AND ONE
THING THAT NANCY PELOSI AND THE
DEMOCRATS DID RIGHT WAS THEY
ORGANIZED VERY EARLY.
THEY KNEW THAT THERE WAS GOING
TO BE ANOTHER ROUND OF STIMULUS.
THEY SET SOME BOUNDARIES FOR
WHAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE FOR,
AND THEY ARE HOLDING ON LIKE RED
ROVER, RED ROVER, SENATE BILL
RIGHT OVER AND THEY WILL
PROBABLY REJECT IT.
AND THE PRESIDENT NEEDS A BILL.
SO THESE NEGOTIATIONS WILL NOT
BE PRETTY AND IT WILL BE VERY,
VERY EXPENSIVE, BUT IT IS AN
INVESTMENT THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
TO MAKE THE ECONOMY COME BACK,
GET PEOPLE SAFE, AND AT THE
SCHOOL’S BACK AS WE TRY TO STAY
HEALTHY.
AND THANK YOU FOR MY TED TALK.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
I COULD TELL THAT YOU WERE
WAITING.
DAGEN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Dagen: IF YOU ARE CYNICAL,
WHICH I AM, THIS IS A WAY FOR
THE DEMOCRATS TO KEEP
UNEMPLOYMENT ABOVE 10% OR EVEN
HIGHER GOING INTO THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION.
SO HERE IS THE WAY PLAYS OUT,
YOU MAKE PEOPLE MORE DEPENDENT
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, YOU
DENY ANY LIABILITY PROTECTION
FOR BUSINESSES, AND THEY CANNOT
BRING PEOPLE BACK ON THE JOB.
THEY CAN’T HIRE NEW WORKERS.
YOU CONTINUE THE $600 EXTRA PER
WEEK, WHICH, BY THE WAY, WHEN
TWO-THIRDS OF THE PEOPLE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT ACCORDING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO ARE MAKING
MORE ON UNEMPLOYMENT THAN THEY
DID IN THEIR JOBS.
SO THEY STAY ON UNEMPLOYMENT,
THEY DON’T GO BACK TO WORK.
AND THEN YOU ALSO HAVE NO SCHOOL
REOPENING.
SO ALL OF THE MOMS OUT THERE OR
EVEN DADS HAVE TO STAY AT HOME
AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR KIDS,
THEY CAN’T GO BACK TO WORK.
YOU LITERALLY WIPE OUT A
GENERATION OF GAINS IN THE
WORKFORCE FOR WOMEN, BUT AGAIN,
IT BENEFITS THE DEMOCRATS,
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
ECONOMY, PARDON MY LANGUAGE
SUCKS, AND BY THE WAY, IF THIS
IS THE BEST THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO THROW BARS AT TERM, THIS
IS A RICH OCTOGENARIAN LIMOUSINE
LIBERAL, AND THAT’S THE BEST
THEY’VE GOT, WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO?
HIT TRUMP WITH THE POCKETBOOK
NEXT?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, SPEAKING OF
THE PRESIDENT, JUAN, I WANT TO
PLAY SOME TAPE, TALKING ABOUT
THE DEATH RATE THAT WE DON’T
HEAR ENOUGH ABOUT, TAKE IT AWAY.
SPEAK OF THE MORTALITY RATE FOR
PATIENCE OVER THE AGE OF 18 IS
85% LOWER THAN IT WAS IN APRIL,
THINK OF THAT.
85%.
AND 25% LOWER THAN EUROPE AS A
WHOLE.
>> Greg: SO THAT’S GOOD NEWS,
JUAN, RIGHT?
>> Juan: I AM ALL FOR IT.
I DON’T WANT ANYBODY TO DIE.
SO THAT’S GOOD NEWS.
I THINK AT THE DASH THE
COUNTERPOINT, GREG, WOULD BE
THAT WE SEE AN INCREASING NUMBER
OF NOT ONLY DEATHS, BUT YOU
KNOW, CORONAVIRUS INFECTION.
BUT TO GET BACK TO YOUR ISSUE
ABOUT THE LIABILITY, I MEAN,
IT’S NOT UNCOMMON FOR PEOPLE TO
HAVE TWO SIGN WAIVERS IF THEY
ARE DOING VOLUNTARY ACTIVITIES,
LIKE IF YOU ARE GOING SKYDIVING,
YOU KNOW?
OR YOU ARE GOING TO A TRUMP
RALLY IN TULSA IN THE MIDST OF A
CORONAVIRUS EPIDEMIC.
SO WE SEE PEOPLE ASKED TO SIGN
THOSE TYPES OF LEADERS.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE, I DON’T
THINK THAT IT IS SO MUCH
POLITICAL, EXCEPT, YOU ARE
RIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL HAVE
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
BUT I DON’T THINK IT IS SO
POLITICAL AND A SENSE THAT YOU
HAVE PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY HAVE TO DO,
WHICH IS GO TO WORK OR BE A
CUSTOMER FOR A BUSINESS, AND
THEY WANT TO FEEL SAFE.
THEY WANT TO BE SURE THAT ANY
BUSINESS IS MAKING EVERY EFFORT
TO PROTECT THEIR WELL-BEING.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU’RE SEEING
THE CONTRARY POINT FROM THE
DEMOCRATS IS YOU CAN’T PASS A
LIABILITY WAIVER THAT FREES
BUSINESS FROM MAKING THE
CUSTOMER SAFETY, WORKER SAFETY A
PRIORITY.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE IT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS THE
HEART AND SOUL OF WHAT IS GOING
ON HERE, THE CONTRARY IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW YOU’RE JUST LETTING
PEOPLE RUN WILD, I THINK THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE WANT TO DO
BUSINESS.
I THINK THAT WE ARE ALL ANXIOUS
FOR IT.
BUT WE WANT TO BE SAFE.
THAT’S ALL.
>> Greg: JESSE, I THINK THAT
WE ALL HAVE GONE OVER THOUGH WE
WANT TO BE SAFE ARGUMENT TO A
POINT THAT WE ARE TRYING TO GET
TO THE NEXT STEP.
WE ASSESS THE RISKS AND THE
BENEFITS, WE ARE ALL ADULTS.
NOBODY WANTS TO GET HURT.
>> Jesse: I AGREE WITH JUAN ON
ONE THING THAT SKYDIVING IS AS
THRILLING AS GOING TO A TRUMP
RALLY.
THAT WAS A VERY ASTUTE.
ON DAGEN McDOWELL, I’M NOT AS
CYNICAL AS DAGEN.
I DON’T THINK NANCY PELOSI WOULD
DESTROY THE COUNTRY JUST TO GET
JOE BIDEN ELECTED.
YES, IT LOOKS LIKE THAT BY
SHUTTING THE ECONOMY DOWN AND
OPENING UP THE BORDERS, BUT I
THINK THAT MAYBE PERHAPS SHE IS
JUST MORE CROOKED, BECAUSE SHE
IS STRESSED IN THE POCKET OF
TRIAL LAWYER LOBBY.
BECAUSE THAT’S WHO WINS.
IF BUSINESSES ARE NOT PROTECTED
AND YOU TEST POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19, YOU CALL A LAWYER, AND
THEN YOU JUST MAKE A LIST OF ALL
THE PLACES YOU WENT IN THE LAST
WEEK, AND THEN YOU SUE YOUR
GROCERIES GOING BACK
GROCERY STORE, YOUR PHARMACY,
AND YOUR BOSS.
AND THEN THE BUSINESSES BACK UP,
THEY ARE GONE, THE ONLY ONES
THAT REMAINED OPEN, THEN THEY
ARE BANKRUPT AFTER ALL OF THIS
MASS LITIGATION.
AND I CAN’T BELIEVE TO WATCH
NANCY, BECAUSE I REMEMBER
WATCHING JOHN BOEHNER, THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER, REMEMBER, HE
USED TO GO ON THE SUNDAY SHOWS
AND THEY WOULD THROW RAZOR
BLADES AT THE GUY, NANCY PELOSI
GETS UP THERE, AND SHE IS
TREATED LIKE ANGELINA JOLIE
PROMOTING A MOVIE, RIGHT?
IT IS A SOFTBALL SITUATION, AND
THEN THERE ARE QUESTIONS AND
AREAS THAT YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO ASK ABOUT.
IN THE NICKNAME DEAL IS IRONIC,
BECAUSE SHE IS REALLY THE LEADER
OF THE DO-NOTHING CONGRESS.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING EXCEPT
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT WHICH JUST
DISTRACTED WASHINGTON FROM THE
PANDEMIC, AND WE HAD THIS GREAT
MOMENT IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE WE
COULD HAVE HAD UNITY, WHERE WE
COULD HAVE FOUGHT AGAINST A
COMMON ENEMY, THE VIRUS AND THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY, AND SHE
JUST THREW IT ALL AWAY AND MADE
TRUMP THE ENEMY.
AND YOU KNOW, LIKE A DAD, I AM